If trading feels confusing,
overwhelming, or like you're just
guessing, I get it. I spent 5 years
stuck there. But once I focused on one
simple scalping strategy, everything
changed for me. I took a small trading
account, built it up over time, and at
one point, I made $10,000 in one single
month. And it's not just me. I've helped
other traders use this exact process I'm
going to show you to become consistently
profitable, too. So, in this video, I'm
going to walk you through the ultimate
scalping roadmap, the exact steps I
would follow if I had to start over from
scratch today. Now, we're going to go
over a lot in this video. I'm going to
build you a foundation of core skills to
understand and analyze the markets.
Then, using those skills, I'm going to
show you the trade entry checklist I and
other traders use every day to find
profitable opportunities. Finally, we'll
apply all of it with a real trade I made
over $1,500 with this morning. And then
by the end of this video, you're going
to be max level, ready to take on
anything the market throws at you. So,
let's start at stage one and get you
started on this process of learning to
make money trading. So when it comes to
scalping, the basics of how it works is
you are looking for shortterm swings or
trades in the market. You are never
looking to hold something long-term
overnight. You are generally trading
using one minute charts, two-minut
charts, or something like a 5-minute
chart. The trades you're in are
generally just a couple of hours at the
most, but can even be a couple of
minutes. The whole idea is that you are
watching the market with a microscope
and you are looking for high probability
setups where you can jump in right at
the correct time and then jump out when
the market shifts to not being worth it
of staying in anymore. You are not
looking for massive home runs, massive
big swings in the market that go over
days. you are generally day trading and
looking for quick moves in the market
and then being done with the day. Now,
there are some major mistakes that a lot
of beginners and traders and myself do
when it comes to scalping that really
makes it hard and probably impossible to
make money consistently. The first one
of those is using bad riskreward ratios.
Let's say you enter a trade here and
your stop loss is down here and you're
risking $200 and the most you hope for
is $100. Well, at a glance it seems like
that's very easy to hit your profit of
$100 very often. But what this does is
over time the math plays out and it's
very hard to consistently make money
doing that. An easy fix of this is
flipping this. Instead of risking
essentially 200 to make 100, you risk
100 to make something like 200. You
don't have to be right as often, but you
make more money when you do, and when
you lose, it's not as big of an issue.
The second mistake is going for tiny
moves in the market where you enter in
here and you get out right here. Again,
it may seem like it's very easy to hit
your profit target, but in the long run,
what you want to be doing is focusing on
those high probability areas where the
concepts that we're going to go over
line up and create a checklist for you
to follow where the probabilities of you
being right skyrocket. And so, you can
get in near the lows of, let's say, a
swing and then jump out when that swing
is kind of done and you can get out with
a really good profit and a low risk. And
then the third major mistake, and I've
fallen prey to this, and I think
everyone does, is trying to capture
every move in the market. It may seem
really simple of a concept, but when
you're looking at a chart and you're
trading, it's so easy to think, okay,
I'm going to jump in here. I'm going to
capture this move, and then I'm going to
catch it on the flip side for a little
bit, and then I'm going to jump in and
capture the swing up again. and looking
at charts, you can see these kind of
potential moves all over the place where
if you think, okay, I'll capture this
swing, capture this one, capture that
one, and when it comes to trading, that
is really impossible to do and you'll
drain yourself and become fatigued and
make bad decisions really, really fast.
when instead what you want to do is have
something like my entry checklist I'm
going to show you where it increases
your probability where you say I am only
looking for this specific thing where
you know five things show up and the
market doesn't do this very often but
when it does it makes a massive move
that I can capture and make a really big
profit from. It's not about taking 10
trades in one day just because you're
scalping. You can be taking one trade a
day, even two trades a whole week, and
you can still be consistently making
money day trading just for a few hours a
day over the long run. That is the key
to becoming successful at this. Now,
before we dive into chart patterns, if
you want to follow along with everything
you're about to see from chart setup to
trade analysis, I highly recommend
getting Ninja Trader. It's the platform
I've used for all my trades for over 5
years. You can get it here via this QR
code or in the link in the description.
So, let's go over the three most
powerful market structure patterns I've
used and seen over time. This is
probably the most important part of this
entire process. And yet, most traders
actually skip over it and just search
for an indicator to tell them when to
buy or sell. But if you can understand
this and these patterns, it will work
way better than any indicator. The first
major thing you need to master is
analyzing just the basics of a trend.
Now, when you first initially look at a
stock chart, it looks all over the
place. There's massive moves up, moves
down, sideways movement. And the best
way I have found to simplify this and
analyze what the direction of the trend
is is to look at the major swings that
you see. If we just look at this move in
the market right here, you can see that
just kind of blurring the candlesticks
together and just making note of the
major swings that it's having is you
just look at where those highs and lows
are in relation to one another. And so a
downtrend like this one is signified by
the highs getting lower and lower over
time and then the lows as well getting
lower and lower over time. And so that's
how you identify a downwards trend. It's
super simple, but using this concept,
you can then also say, okay, well now
right here, you can see it starts to
switch, right? It starts to go kind of
sideways. And that's essentially where a
sideways trend is, where the highs and
the lows are roughly the same. It
doesn't have to be exactly at the same
price. You can have a sideways trend
that is like this where it's still kind
of all over the place, but if you look
at it as a whole and not zoom in on the
specific candlesticks, it's generally
the price over this time is going
sideways. That is the biggest key to
focus on. And then an uptrend is
signified by the opposite where it's
consistently making higher highs and
higher lows where the highs are
essentially breaking above the high of
the last one. And then same thing with
the lows is over time they're
consistently getting higher. Now you
don't want to get bogged down in all the
little micro highs and the lows it has.
The key is you want to be looking at
kind of the major swings that it's
clearly having. That's going to tell you
the trend and the direction that it's
going to go. And with these trends is
you can have trends that are very
fastpaced going up or you can have ones
that are a little slower where they're
kind of just slowly chugging along in
that direction. There's not just one
sizefits-all. Now the second thing we've
got is a way to help read these trends
and easily understand what they're doing
are using trend lines or channels. You
can visually notice that the lows are
consistently matching along the bottom
if you draw a line touching the swings.
And so for an example is here. If we
look at this trend, this is a little
different than normal. Usually you would
say, okay, for a downtrend, I'm going to
match the highs here, but the trend up
here breaks before it, you know,
consistently shows more. One thing you
can do though is on the other side, you
can say, well, the lows here are
consistently matching where it bounces
off these two. I can draw a line off of
just two swings. That's really what you
need to confirm it. And then you can see
by this third one, you could see that it
was going to bounce there. And then
where it came down here another a fourth
time is it was pretty helpful to say,
okay, that's where it's bouncing off of.
And then what you can do actually is you
can take this and move it to the other
side. And if it's in a good channel is
the other side will bounce off of it
when it hits that area. As you can see
here, it actually bounced this off of it
initially and then it eventually broke
that because the trend changed and the
trend channel broke. We'll get into a
minute on those signals and kind of how
you can use those to predict where the
trend's going to go. But essentially,
when you're just looking at moves in the
market, it'll help a lot to visually be
looking for them. That's why I suggest
when you look at a chart, practice and
visually be thinking about, okay, where
are potential trend lines that show me
where the trend is going and what it's
doing. Now on the flip side, you can
also do this with horizontal levels to
show where supply and demand is. And
these are essentially horizontal support
versus trend line or trending supports.
And these supply and demand zones are
very helpful in a more sideways trend
because you can predict okay based off
of these two swings here. And I like to
actually use a box instead of a line
because again the market never hits an
exact price. It's always just kind of
well up in this zone in this area based
off of these two swings. I'm going to
expect if it comes down and pushes up
here again well we might lose steam a
third time and I can take a trade off of
that. And so that's the basics of how
those work. And so when you kind of zoom
out, you can see actually big picture
here is that if you look at the larger
trend of the major swings and you can
always go to a higher time frame chart
to kind of make this easier is that well
there's clearly a supply zone up here
where every time the market comes up
here it bounces. And you could also do
that for the lows here is every time the
market comes down here well there is a
bounce that the market has. Now that you
understand what these three major market
patterns mean, let me show you how to
use them to predict what the market's
going to do. If you've ever felt like
trading didn't click, this next section
is really going to bring it all
together. So if we go back to each one
of these, if we look at market
structure, well, the basics of using
that lower highs and higher lows, well,
as soon as that you start to see a shift
of a higher low and a higher high right
here, you can start to say, well, the
trend is starting to shift. This is a
signal that the trend is slowing down
from a downtrend and starting to move
into either a sideways trend or an
upwards trend. And so through that, that
is your first major indicator for seeing
a trend potentially change. And you can
use that to capture potential reversals
in the market. Now, if we take that and
add that on to using our trend lines or
trend channels, you can see that okay,
well, once this trend line is broken,
that's a second confirmation that this
downtrend is coming to an end. And we
can expect that it either starts to slow
down or we could take a trade and
capture an opportunity in the market.
That's the whole idea with these
concepts is you're starting to build a
foundation to have things align up all
at once and to create a highly probable
spot where you're correct about what the
market's going to do next. So often it
is so hard to really know what's going
on in the market. And so that's why you
don't want to be trying to take every
trade in the market. A lot of times
things are kind of crazy in the market
and you want to wait until it's very
clear and you have a clear
understanding. So then you can risk
taking a trade and putting your money on
the line to take a profitable trade. Now
there's a couple ways that actually a
trend line or trend channel can break.
Now, another one is where it overshoots
the channel where instead of bouncing
off the bottom of the channel here, it
breaks through the channel and and
essentially gets overextended, oversold,
and it will then reverse based off of
that. And so those are two ways to look
for the trend shifting based on a
channel break. Now, the next thing is
looking at your supply and demand zones.
If I went here, had this pattern here
show up, I would have thought, okay,
this is a good spot to look for the
market to reverse. It's come up here
multiple times. The uptrend is clearly
broken, especially after this sell-off.
And so, if we come up here again, I want
to look for it to reverse again. It's a
good spot to look for that to happen.
And so going into this, you can see that
if I put this box at the extreme high
here, the market here actually broke the
high of this area. And so when I first
started out trading, I thought, okay, it
broke the high. It's making new highs
and this supply level is broken. The
markets, you know, showing that it's
super strong. It's had this massive move
up here. It's probably just going to
continue trending higher. And so I'm not
going to look for a a potential short
here to bet the market's going to go
lower at this level that I've clearly
identified before that is potentially a
good spot for it to happen. And so
instead though, knowing what I know now
is a lot of times what can happen is
it's a failed breakout. The market likes
to pretend to break these levels in the
sense of it likes to make, you know,
noobs like I used to be think that,
okay, this is going to go long here.
Maybe I should buy here. bet the
market's going to go up. And so it traps
those people, but also people that are
maybe in a larger trade that have their
stops up here that are already betting,
people that are in maybe a bigger time
frame trade that have their stop losses
above this high before. Well, it comes
up here, knocks them out of their trade,
and then goes back down. Essentially,
it's liquidity hunting, some people call
it. And from there, it sells off, starts
to kind of go sideways. you know, it
loses that steam and then the big
picture eventually plays out and it
pushes lower. And you can see it kind of
happened here again. And so that's why I
don't like to discount something when
it's broken like that. And so if you
combine these concepts of the highs and
the lows starting to slow down here and
making lower lows and lower highs, just
looking at the swings, that's showing
you that the trend is slowing down,
starting to shift. And if you combine
that with the fact that you're already
at a spot based on a supply and demand
zone that you think the market's going
to slow down, well, that's just two good
signals that, okay, well, maybe the
market's going to push lower here and I
can make money betting that it's going
to go down. So, I highly suggest you
open a chart on Ninja Trader for
yourself and practice looking for these
concepts. It takes time to get used to
reading a chart. Now that you've learned
the skills to analyze the market, we can
actually start leveling you up to
understand how to take advantage of the
opportunities the market gives you.
Every one of these steps is what I wish
I knew when I started. This is going to
be your shortcut. So, step one of this
process is looking for those key
reversal zones. Just like we were
talking about with those concepts
before, you want to be looking at where
the major areas in the market are that
it's likely to reverse off of. This is
the biggest key I found to finding those
high probability zones. Because if you
think about it, looking at this, it's
easy to see, okay, when the market comes
up here, it's likely that it's going to
go down. But anywhere in the middle
here, it's really hard to know what it's
going to do. Is it going to chop? Is it
going to sell off to the lows in some
kind of fashion? It's hard to be able to
consistently make profitable trades when
the market is moving like this and
you're trying to predict the direction
it's going to go compared to when it's
at an extreme. That makes it way more
likely for it to be overextended and it
needs to snap back in some fashion. And
those are the high probability spots
that you want to be scalping for. It
allows you to jump in and jump out very
easily at those swings and avoid all the
crazy noise in the middle. And so a
couple keys to this is for me when I'm
trading I usually enter in on a 1 or a
5minut chart. But to draw these levels I
look at a higher time frame of usually a
15 or 30 minute chart. This just allows
me to kind of look at the bigger picture
and focus on those key extremes in the
market because sticking to those
extremes is what is going to make you
more profitable. Trying to capture, like
I said in the beginning, all those
little swings in the middle, it's just
going to lose you money in the long run.
Now, to draw these levels, I always
suggest looking for two major swings.
So, you want to see the market pop up
and sell off from the same area twice
before you look for a third time of it
testing that and looking to assume that
it's going to go to the downside. Now,
now we were mainly looking at a
resistance or a supply zone. This
totally works on the flip side, too. If
the market comes down here, I would look
for a potential bounce off of this area
as well. And so, that's the nice thing
about this is you can trade it in both
directions. doesn't matter if the
market's going up or down for you to
make money consistently. Now, the second
thing is using a lot of those concepts
that we talked about is trend analysis
is analyzing the trend as it comes into
that major level. When it's coming down,
let's say to flip it now into a level
that you've liked so far. When it's
coming down into this, you want to see,
okay, what is the trend? Is there a
downtrend in play? and when does that
break? You want to only be looking for
the market to potentially bounce off of
this when you can see clearly that the
trend into that level is broken.
Otherwise, you're just gambling that it
it could bounce off of this level. It's
so hard to know if a level is going to
hold or not until you see the trend
start to shift. And so some couple key
things about that is, you know, using
those trend lines of the just the basic
swing highs and the swing lows like we
talked about of just keeping track of
those. And then once those start to
shift, once it goes from making lower
lows and lower highs to now making maybe
a double bottom or a higher low to
making a higher high, that's when you
can start to see, okay, it's starting to
shift. And if that aligns up with a
support level, that's where you want to
be saying, "Okay, step two is now done."
Now, step three is you start to
essentially get more and more narrowed.
As you can see through this process,
looking at a chart is, you know, the big
picture is looking at, okay, where's the
big major area where I want to wait for
the market to come up and potentially
reverse off of? And then the next thing
is okay, I want to make sure that trend
essentially slows down before I get in
short. And so the whole idea of this is
you can see it's kind of looking at the
big picture and slowly zooming in. The
first idea is, you know, okay, I want to
wait for this major level. Next is I
want to make sure that the trend that
goes into this level, I want to wait for
it to slow down. I want to wait for it
to stop making higher highs and higher
lows and show me a reason to jump in
that it's slowing down. The next part of
that is looking at a candlestick
pattern. And now the whole idea of this
third step is essentially when it comes
up to your level here, you're looking
for that trend to break and then you're
looking for a candlestick pattern to
help you confirm that okay, this swing
here, this push-up is going to start
failing because otherwise, how do you
know in real time when this is going to
form? It's easy to know after the fact,
you know, once you can see the swings
that, okay, well, it's clearly in a
downtrend now off this level. You know,
I should have jumped in here right now.
So, how do you confirm right here that
you are right there in real time before
any of this has taken place? And so, the
whole idea with that is we're looking
for a candlestick pattern at this area
when the market's forming that. It's
going to make a ton more sense in the
live example that we're going to go over
in a minute. But a couple of key things
that you want to do with this is first
off, you need to not have a lot of chop
going into this. To show you what I mean
is if we actually look at this spot on
the chart we've been looking at is right
now moving up into this level, you can
see it's starting to slow down, but
there's a lot of chop back and forth,
right? If if we look at say, hey, this
was maybe a swing high in real time. If
we're going to say this is a swing high
up here and I actually think that right
here, well, it's technically made a
lower high and that could be a
confirmation of okay, I want to jump in.
But overall, going into this and even
moving a little bit forwards to this one
right here, it's been kind of choppy
back and forth. It's better to wait for
it to be a lot clearer of moving into
this level, making a high, and then
starting to sell off. If you have a ton
of candles that are just kind of
stacking up and not making that much
movement vertically, it's showing you
that the market's kind of at an
equilibrium and it's more likely to
start to chop around for a while before
it gets moving. versus if I compare it
to this guy over here, the market here,
it did chop for a little while and hit
equilibrium. But because of going into
this level, it had crazy moves up into
this with very little chop at that level
versus the last one, it was showing that
it was overextended and it's likely to
kind of have that whip back. Now, a
couple of key patterns I like to
consistently use are a double top and a
head and shoulders pattern. I've
actually got a really sick PDF guide
that you can download for free. I'll put
in the link in the description of this
video. It essentially has 14 pages of
patterns that I use, theories of why
they work, the reality of what they look
like, keys to the pattern, and then
actually things to avoid with the
pattern of what can give it a false
reading. And so, I highly recommend you
get that. It's totally free. You'll just
find it in the description of this
video. that'll really help with
identifying those major patterns. And as
well, the fourth step now is looking at
candlestick confirmations. This is kind
of the last step of jumping into a
trade. And all of this will really make
a lot more sense when I show you this
real trade example we're going to go
over in a minute. But the main things to
look for this is again, you want to
avoid that chop still. You want clear
candlestick strength. Two major patterns
I like to look for are either engulfing
candlestick patterns or the threeline
strike patterns. And so if we actually
go to another page from that guide that
you can get down below is the threeline
strike pattern. Essentially what it does
is the whole idea is that the market's
kind of moving up methodically. The
candlesticks are looking kind of roughly
the same size here and then all of a
sudden you have a massive bearish
candlestick that is huge compared to the
previous candlesticks. What that shows
is a lot of strength. This is
essentially the final confirmation that
okay the trend is up but I'm looking for
it to you know fail at this resistance
area. you know, we've had the lower lows
and lower highs. And so once I see kind
of this candlestick, it shows that the
momentum is switching and it's likely to
continue down lower because of these
bigger picture factors that we have
aligned up to essentially create a
domino effect of entering into a trade
and finding a high probability setup
that is likely to work out. Now, the
final step for this is actually entering
in the trade. When it comes down to
actually entering in the trade, and you
see all this stuff, a lot of emotions
come up. It's scary. And so, I want to
give you the tools, and we'll definitely
do this a lot more in the live example
here in a second of how to do it
properly. Now, remember, I haven't gone
over trading math a ton in this video,
but stick to a positive riskreward ratio
where you're risking $100 to make
something either like
$200 or $300 because it allows it to
where if you're wrong, it's not that big
of a deal because every time you're
right, and even if you're right 50% of
the time, these profits that you make
when you do win outweigh the losses that
happen. And so over time, if you take
something like 10 trades, 100 trades,
you'll consistently be making money on
average. Now, a couple of things to
think about. The biggest mistake that
people do when actually entering into a
trade or managing a trade is they will
increase their risk during the trade.
They'll kind of get married to the
trade. Essentially, they'll, you know,
enter in here and they'll put their stop
loss down here. And so, the tra, you
know, the market kind of goes here. They
enter in, it goes up a little and it
comes down. And what they do is they
move their stop loss further away
because they think, "Okay, well, I still
think it looks really good. I know, you
know, it just needs a little more room,
right?" And what that does is it
increases your risk to, let's say, $200.
And now the math up here, you've totally
ruined by doing that. Now, you don't
know what's going to happen to one
trade. It can be the best looking setup
you have ever seen. The stars can be
aligning. You think it's going to be a
massive home run and some random news
could pop out. You know, some politician
could say something. The market could
just bleep lower real quick. That can
totally happen and you'll have lost more
than you should have and really blown up
the whole process that trading is. And
so, this kind of goes along with plan
your exit before entering. You need to
have a plan of when you're jumping in a
trade right here, where is your stop
loss going to go and where is your
takerit going to go? Is it going to be a
fixed profit target based on just going
for $200 or $300 or is it going to be
something that you slowly manage over
time? This is very, very important to
know before you jump into the trade.
Otherwise, you're going to make
emotional mistakes like moving your stop
loss further down or tightening up your
profit target and getting out of this
trade way earlier than you should have
because you got scared that well, I just
want to get out. I want this thing to
work out and I just want to kind of be
done with it. It's really frustrating.
You know, that's kind of the things that
will run through your head as you're in
a trade. Now, let's take these concepts,
you know, and let me show you exactly
how I entered a real money trade this
morning using this checklist and
analyzing the market in real time with
the concepts we've used. It's easy to
find these after the fact, but if you
watch how I actually analyze and entered
this trade, you'll see how it's possible
to spot profitable moves before they
happen and take advantage of them. So,
first thing that I do every day that I
come into trading, I open my charts to
the larger time frame and look for those
big key levels. And so, today I was
watching oil futures and I was looking
at this major swings that we've had in
it. Essentially, the markets bounced
here twice already. And so, I liked this
area for a potential bounce. This was
looking at a 30inut chart here. And if
we look at a 15-inute chart here, it's
pretty much the same. is it's come down,
bounced, bounced here a little bit and
then come back down to test it again.
And you can see it's actually done a
failed breakout here. And so that's
where my step one was taken care of. I
looked at, okay, this is a major level I
think we're likely to bounce off of. We
have a big trend if we look into this
area where the markets come down here
and it's clearly going sideways at this
point. you know, the highs here are
roughly the same, the lows here roughly
the same. And so to me, that signals
that, okay, this downtrend is over.
We're at this area. And so, I think it's
likely that those two factors are going
to help potentially push us higher, big
picture. And so, that's pretty much step
two of analyzing the current trend. Now,
one last trend factor is once I zoomed
into a five minute chart, I sometimes
enter in on a one minute or a five
minute. For me, I've noticed for oil, 5
minutes is a little better. 1 minute is
a little too choppy. It doesn't move as
fast pace as some other charts that work
with a 5minute. But if we look at this
big move down right here to continue to
analyze the trend, this is a move I love
to see because what this signals to me
is that the market has made a really
fast move down here and so likely it's
overextended. It's not a healthy move.
If I kind of look for another one here,
as you can see, the market moved down
here very quickly and then it had to
essentially snap back to about 50% of
this move. If I pull up actually a
Fibonacci tool here, take the high here
of the swing and the low here, the
midpoint between those is right here,
it's essentially at 50%. That is a very
common spot I find where fast moves like
this will pull back to. It's essentially
a healthy retracement of the market
saying, "Okay, I'm overextended. You
know, people who have caught this move
need to sell." And it's very likely it's
going to do that. And so for me, that is
a great spot to think of. Okay, well, if
I look at this move here, well, we've
made that healthy retracement already.
And so that's not good in terms of if
I'm trying to just capture this quick
move from the lows back up. But in terms
of it continuing lower, that's where
it'll usually pull back before it
continues lower. And so if it comes
here, does that, and this continue lower
fails, and it makes a higher low here
than this one, well, that's a really
good signal that it's going to continue
higher. And so on a smaller time frame,
you know, smaller picture, that's kind
of this pattern playing out. And then
hopefully, you know, if you look at the
bigger picture is that the larger
pattern of bouncing off this support
level will play out too. And so if we
move on to step three now, we want to be
looking for a nice candlestick pattern.
And so what I like to look for a lot of
the time with these situations is
essentially that higher low being
confirmed there or a double bottom. And
so if I actually pull this up in real
time now, this is my chart getting
recorded from this morning. And so
essentially at this point, this is where
I'm thinking, okay, I want to see a
large candlestick here form because
that's going to help me with step three
and four. Basically, it's going to show
me a double bottom. And then it's also
going to be that strong engulfing
candlestick that confirms that. And so
right here, you can see I'm I'm using
essentially a tool to say, okay, if I
enter here and my stop loss is here, how
much do I want to enter in on the trade?
And then where is you know my riskreward
ratio is going to be. And so essentially
once I wait for that to confirm I like
to let the next candlestick play out a
little bit because sometimes a big
candlestick like that can have a little
of a bit of a pullback before it keeps
going higher. Minor detail but
essentially what I'm looking for now is
okay I'm going to enter in long at the
break of this pattern and as it goes
higher. And so what I do is you actually
see there's no order here on the screen,
but I've entered in a long here and put
my stop loss down here. The only reason
why it doesn't show up is actually just
because my account on this recording
screen wasn't selected for a little
while. But if we zoom forwards, you can
see I entered in here and I put my stop
loss below here. Essentially the bottom
of that swing. The whole idea of why I
put my stop loss there is because I
don't want the market to if the market
comes up here, makes a pretty clean
higher low and then comes up and breaks
that, I think the trend's going to
continue lower. And so I just want to
kind of get out because I'm getting
mixed signals. I want the signals for
the trade to be clear and for me to jump
in on the trade. And so with with this
trade, I think I'm risking about $800.
And so as we move up, I'm looking at a
few key factors to manage it. Now,
before I show you how to manage this
trade, pause and think, where would you
exit this trade based on what you know
so far about market structure, all the
concepts I've taught you in this video,
I use them to manage my trades in real
time. Now, if you actually pause and
critically think about this, you're
already doing what 90% of traders won't.
And so to walk you through how I plan to
do this is well obviously the major
swing I'd love to go for is somewhere up
here. That would be holding overnight
multiple days and that's not really what
I was looking for today especially
because it's a Friday. It's going into a
long weekend actually with a holiday on
Monday. Now, obviously you didn't know
that, but just looking at the patterns
here is well, the market's starting to
kind of slow down. And so, there's
potential resistance zones here where I
think the market could slow down. I also
think a big picture kind of more looking
at a 30 minute is if we look at this,
well, the major kind of swing down it
had when it started to accelerate was
kind of this area right here. And so I
would think a good spot would be to give
uh back up to here if it really started
to get going. And so that's essentially
what I'm doing every time I'm in a trade
is I'm thinking about where are the
potential for not necessarily major. You
don't necessarily need to be targeting a
major swing or a major supply or demand
level, but also looking at these smaller
ones because now that we're in a trade,
those can still reverse the market.
They're not necessarily where I want to
enter in on the market, but they are at
a spot where I want to potentially get
out or take some of the trade off. And
so right here, you can see as the market
started to push up here, it's had a
really nice move. It's essentially given
up this major move down. I have moved my
trade to break even. It's really
important to take that risk off the
table because going forwards, well, I
don't want it to come up here all the
way down and I actually end up losing
$800 on the day when I was up over $800.
That's just kind of, you know,
math-wise, you got to kind of go with
that. And the helpful part is it had
this little micro pullback here. That's
when I kind of moved it up. And then
from there in a minute here, I put in a
limit order at this high here because I
wanted to say I don't want to manage it
in real time. I want to just get out of
half of my trade of one of my contracts
out of my two when it punches up to this
level. And so right there, you can see
it closed. And so I closed off, took
about half my profits there. And then
with the idea is that I'm buying at the
major support here. I want to see if
this will continue higher and I can get
even more out of this, but I don't want
to be greedy. It's at a definite spot
where I think it can slow down. And so I
want to take some off. And so that limit
order that just showed up there, I put
it up here in case we did just skyrocket
up there. That was the spot I wanted to
take the trade off. At that point, I
would have been super happy. I think it
would have been four times my risk in
terms of profit at least for half of
that trade. But going back to the
concepts that we talked about, you can
see I have a trend line here. And this
upwards trend that is going on here is a
very unhealthy or onedirectional trend.
And so my thought is I'm okay holding
this as long as it holds this trend
line. But as soon as it kind of starts
to break that, it could pull back in a
big way. And at this point, I'm thinking
that, hey, this is a great move. I don't
want to hold through a big pullback. and
push higher. I was able to break up my
trade into maybe having a smaller amount
on here. And so at this point, I was
essentially just watching this and
saying, "Okay, I'm going to get out."
And so, just to zoom forwards here is it
had a little bit of a bottom here, moved
my stop loss up there, and then it
eventually broke that right there. And
so, that's how I take this whole process
and turn it into a step-by-step
checklist that you can now use for
yourself. And so you now have unlocked
all these concepts and this checklist to
be able to attack the market every day.
Now it's your turn. Start analyzing
these patterns and practicing trade
setups using Ninja Trader. Use what
you've learned to spot opportunities and
build confidence as you go. And if you
want a more in-depth breakdown of this
scalping style with more examples, check
out this next video. It'll take you even
deeper into this strategy.